.
THEY WERE BARRED FROM THAT.
SO THEY CREATED THEIR OWN.
THREE ASTRONAUTS BOUND FOR THE
HEAVENLY PALACE.
THAT'S CHINA'S SPACE STATION
STILL UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
FROM A LAUNCH PAD IN THE GOBI
DEZ ERLTD, THE ROCKETSHIP,
DUBBED THE DEFINE VESSEL,
BLASTING OFF, DESIGNED TO ARRIVE
AT ITS DESTINATION IN JUST SIX
AND A HALF HOURS.
BUT AT A TOTAL LENGTH OF 55 FEET
AND A LIVING SPACE OF JUST 50
CUBIC METERS THESE ASTRONAUTS
ARE GOING INTO ORBIT IN A
CAPSULE A BIG LARGER THAN A CITY
BUS.
ANY CLAW STROH PHOBIC THOUGHT
FORGOTTEN WHEN THEY DO TWO
PLANNED SPACE WALKS.
INSIDE THEY WILL TEST THE TECH
AND THE LIVING AREA AND RUN
EXPERIMENTS.
MORE LABORATORY MODULES EXPECT
TO BE LAUNCHED IN UPCOMING
MISSIONS WITH THE AIMS TO HAVE
ITS SPACE STATION FULLY
OPERATIONAL BY THE END OF NEXT
YEAR.
CHINA WANTS ITS OWN BECAUSE THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT BARRED IT FROM
PARTICIPATIONING IN THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
PROJECT.
CHINA SAYS THE HEAVENLY PALACE
WILL BE CERTAINLY INTERNATIONAL.
>> FOREIGN ASTRONAUTS ARE GOING
TO ENTER INTO THE CHINESE SPACE
STATION ONE DAY.
A NUMBER OF COUNTRIES EXPRESSED
A DESIRE TO DO THAT AND WE WILL
BE OPEN TO THAT IN THE FUTURE.
>> Reporter: IN JUST SEVEN
MONTHS CHINA HAS PUT A ROVER ON
THE MOON AND ONE ON MARS
BECOMING THE SECOND COUNTRY IN
HISTORY TO LAPPED A ROVER ON THE
RED PLANET.
THEY ALSO PLAN TO SEND HUMANS TO
THE MOON IN THE 2030s.
FOR NOW, THESE THREE MEN WILL
SPEND THREE MONTHS BUILDING THE
FOUNDATION OF THE SPACE STATION.
>> Translator: WE WILL OBEY
ORDERS AND INSTRUCTIONS AND KEEP
CALM WHILE METICULOUSLY CARRYING
OUT THE MISSION.
>> Reporter: CHINESE EXPERTS
LIKEWISE CONFIDENT IN THIS
MISSION AND ITS SAFE RETURN TO
EARTH AS THE VESSEL CARRIES
PRECIOUS CARGO ALONG WITH THE
PRIDE OF A NATION RAPIDLY
ADVANCING ITS WORK IN THIS NEW
FRONTIER.
BECKY U MIGHT RECALL LAST MONTH
CHINA FACED A LOT OF CRITICISM
MAINLY FROM THE U.S. WITH AN OUT
OF CONTROL ROCKET THAT WAS
RETURNING TO EARTH AND IT WAS
FEARED IT WOULD CAUSE DAMAGE OR
HARM.
IT DIDN'T.
IT SPLASHED IN THE OCEAN.
NONETHELESS, THEY REDEEMED
THEMSELVES WITH THIS PRECISION
PERFECT LAUNCH TODAY AND THE
MISSION UNDER WAY NOW IS GOING
TO LAST THREE MONTHS.
THINK ABOUT THE TIMING OF THIS.
THIS IS HAPPENING JUST A COUPLE
OF WEEKS BEFORE THIS COUNTRY
CELEBRATES THE CHINA COMMUNIST
PARTY'S 100th ANNIVERSARY.
IT IS CERTAINLY BEING TALKED
ABOUT ON LINE HERE.
>> FASCINATING.
DAVID, THANK YOU.
>>> CHINA HAS MADE EXTREMELY
HEAVY INVESTMENTS FROM REALIZING
ITS SPACE AMBITIONS FROM ITS
FIRST SATELLITE LAUNCH IN 1970
TO SUCCESSFULLY PUTTING A ROVER
ON MARS JUST LAST YEAR.
YOU CAN SEE JUST HOW MUCH MONEY
IT IS INVESTING COMPARED TO THE
OTHER MAJOR SPACE PLAYERS.
AN $11 BILLION BUDGET, ACCORDING
TO THE LATEST DATA, WAY AHEAD OF
RUSSIA OR CHINA, FOR EXAMPLE.
ITS GOALS ARE LOFTY GOING
FORWARD, NOT ONLY AIMING TO
FULLY CREW ITS OWN SPACE STATION
BY 2022.
BUT ALSO PUTTING A
CHINESE/RUSSIAN BASE ON THE MOON
BY THE 2030s.
IT'S ALSO AIMING TO CREW
MISSIONS TO MARS BY THE YEAR
2050.
WELL, MY NEXT GUEST CO-CHAIRED
THE BIPARTISAN U.S./CHINA
WORKING GROUP.
THE GROUP WAS THE FIRST
DELEGATION TO VISIT THE LAUNCH
CENTER IN GOBI DESERT.
ALSO A U.S. HOUSE CHAIRMAN.
U.S. REPRESENTATIVE RICK LARSON
JOINING ME FROM THE U.S.
CHINA NOW HAS ITS OWN SPACE
STATION.
MORE THAN A DOZEN OTHER
COUNTRIES INVOLVED IN THE ISS,
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
FROM THE U.S. PERSPECTIVE, HOW
MUCH OF A THREAT, REGARDING
NATIONAL SECURITY OR OTHERWISE,
IS THIS EXTREMELY AMBITIOUS
CHINESE SPACE PROJECT AND THIS
NEW SPACE STATION THAT WAS BUILT
AND WILL BE RUN BY CHINA?
>> I THINK THAT THE UNITED
STATES AND THE REST OF THE WORLD
NEEDS TO LOOK AT SPACE AS A
PLACE WHERE THERE IS AS LITTLE
CONFLICT AS POSSIBLE.
SO I THINK THERE IS ROOM FOR THE
U.S., CHINA, RUSSIA, AND OTHERS
THAT PLAY IN SPACE TO REALLY
COME TOGETHER TO INSURE THAT
SPACE AMBITIONS AREN'T ANY MORE
A THREAT THAN THEY ARE TODAY.
AND SHOULD NOT COME AS A
SURPRISE WHAT CHINA IS DOING.
I WAS AT THE SPACE LAUNCH
FACILITY IN 2009 IN THE MIDDLE
AGAI
GOBI DESERT.
IT IS A TOP FLIGHT -- LITERALLY
A TOP FLIGHT FACILITY.
I HAVE BEEN TO THEIR ASTRONAUT
TRAINING FACILITY IN CHINA.
THEY ARE -- THE U.S. TRIED TO
STOP THIS FROM HAPPENING THROUGH
SANKS IN THE EARLY 2000s, BUT
IT'S CLEAR THAT CHINA IS MAKING
THIS INVESTMENT.
>> THERE ARE CLAIMS THAT IT IS
WASHINGTON'S FAULT IN A THE U.S.
AND CHINA AREN'T WORKING TO THE
IN SPACE.
THE AMERICANS AND THE SOVIETS
MANAGED TO WORK TOGETHER ON
SPACE PROMISE DURING THE COLD
WAR.
DO YOU THINK THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE U.S. AND
CHINA GOING FORWARD?
AFTER ALL, DAVID KORVER POINTED
OUT IN HIS REPORT THAT FOREIGN
ASTRONAUTS ARE LIKELY OR
CERTAINLY ARE INVITED TO ENTER
THE CSS IN THE FUTURE.
>> YEAH, I REMEMBER I THINK I
WAS 9 OR 10 WHEN THE SOYUZ SPACE
CAPSULE WENT UP AND THERE WAS
COOPERATION.
AT THE MOST IN THE EARLY OR MID
2000s IN CONGRESS I AND THE
REPUBLICANS WERE TRYING TO GET
THE U.S. AND RUSSIA AND CHINA TO
DESIGN A COMMON DOCKING FACILITY
IN CASE THERE WAS A NECESSITY TO
RESCUE ASTRONAUTS IN SPACE
STATIONS JUST SO THE DOCKING
RINGS MATCHED UP NO MATTER WHICH
COUNTRY.
BUT WE COULDN'T GET PEOPLE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES TO DO
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
WE WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT JOINT
MISSIONS, WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT
SHARING TECHNOLOGY.
JUST THE SAME DOCKING MECHANISMS
IN CASE THERE WAS A NEED TO
RESCUE PEOPLE IN SPACE AND
CONGRESS WASN'T WILLING TO GO
THAT FAR.
>> DO YOU SEE THAT AS A BIG
LOSS?
YOU HAVE SAID, YOU KNOW, IT
WOULD BE -- WE SHOULD LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK WITH CHINA
IN SPACE.
WE HEAR A SIMILAR RHETORIC FROM
WASHINGTON ABOUT WORKING WITH
CHINA IN CLIMATE CHANGE AROUND
THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND THERE WILL BE THOSE WATCHING
THIS TODAYS IT WILL BE
FASCINATING TO HEAR WASHINGTON
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
WORK WITH CHINA WHEN IT SUITS
THEM BUT NOT ACROSS TRADE, TECH,
SATISFACTORYIOUS OTHER THINGS
WHERE WE ARE SEEING -- AND WE
HAVE SEEN THIS WITH JOE BIDEN'S
RECENT TRIP TO EUROPE WHERE
CHINA WAS IN THE METAPHORICAL
CROSS HAIRS TALKING ABOUT HOW WE
COUNTER CHINA GOING FORWARD.
>> THERE ARE AREAS WHERE THE
UNITED STATES AND OUR POLICIES
HERE AND THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
POLICIES WILL BE IN CONFLICT,
WILL BE IN COMPETITION.
TRADE IS AN AREA ON THE ECONOMIC
SIDE.
THERE ARE OTHER AREAS AS WELL.
THERE ARE AREAS OF COOPERATION
AS WELL.
I CAN THINK ABOUT ON NORTH
KOREA, ON CLIMATE CHANGE,
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM.
ON THIS ISSUE OF SPACE, THERE IS
A WAY TO APPROACH THIS SO THAT
THE SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY SORT
OF STAYS INSIDE THE SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY BOX WITHOUT GETTING
OUTSIDE OF THAT WHERE IT BECOMES
A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE FOR
EITHER COUNTRY.
BUT WE DO -- WE WOULD BOTH
BENEFIT FROM SOME COOPERATION IN
SPACE.
AGAIN, I THINK IT WILL PROBABLY
BE -- IF IT DOES HAPPEN, IT
WOULD HAPPEN INSIDE SOME SORT OF
DESCRIBED SET OF BOUNDARIES THAT
PREVENT NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUES
FROM BECOMING TOO MUCH IN THE
FOREFRONT.
>> A COUPLE OF OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR YOU.
VERY BRIEFLY, DO YOU SEE A
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE VERY SORT
OF -- I DON'T WANT TO CALL IT
BELLI COAST BUT THE VERY SORT OF
NOISY RHETORIC WE HEAR FROM
WASHINGTON WITH REGARD CHINA AND
COUNTERING CHINA'S, YOU KNOW,
GROWING INFLUENCE NOT LEAST IN
THE FIELD OF TECH AND U.S.
BUSINESS, WHICH IS VERY MUCH
LOOKING TO CHINA AS A GROWTH
OPPORTUNITY GOING FORWARD.
I AM THINKING ABOUT THE BEING
FINANCE HOUSES FOR EXAMPLE.
>> I THINK THAT THE -- WHERE THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT POLICY AND THE
BIDEN/HARRIS ADMINISTRATION AND
WHERE U.S. BUSINESS CAN COME
TOGETHER IS IN THE AREA OF WHAT
WE ARE TRYING TO DO HERE AT
HOME.
THE U.S. INNOVATION AND
COMPETITIVE ACT HAS PASSED THE
SENATE.
WE ARE TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
SIMILAR HERE IN THE U.S. HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
THIS WOULD BE A MAJOR INVESTMENT
IN THE BASIC INFRASTRUCTURE,
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND THE ROADS
BRIDGES HIGHWAYS NOTICE OF HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN ECONOMIC
HOUSE IN ORDER.
I JUST TALKED WITH AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CHINA THIS
MORNING ABOUT THESE ISSUES, THIS
MORNING D.C. TIME ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
AND WE ARE ALL IN AGREEMENT THAT
GETTING OUR OWN HOUSE IN ORDER
IS PART OF BEING COMPETITIVE
VIS-A-VIS CHINA, AND THE U.S.
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS FOUR
SQUARE BEHIND THOSE EFFORTS.
>> VERY BRIEFLY, BIPARTISAN
MEMBERS OF THE U.S. HOUSE WILL
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION THIS WEEK
TO BOOST U.S. SUPPORT FOR
TAIWAN.
HOW DO YOU PLAN TO BOOST SUPPORT
WHILE AVOIDING DRIVING A WEDGE
EVEN FURTHER BETWEEN WASHINGTON
AND BEIJING AT THIS POINT?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THE
BIDEN/HARRIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN AT ALL KOI OR SHY ABOUT
DEMONSTRATING TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND CHINESE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE ARE GOING TO
STAND UP FOR OUR VALUES AND OUR
INTERESTS AND APPROACH THOSE IN
A WAY WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
THAT'S THROUGH WORKING WITH
FRIENDS, PARTNERS, AND ALLIES IN
THE REGION.
AND IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH TAIWAN.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE
BIDEN/HARRIS TEAM HAS THEIR EYES
WIDE OPEN IN THIS REGARD AS WELL
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT MAY RESPOND IN SOME
WAY BUT ARE WILLING TO DEAL WITH
THAT RESPONSE IN AN APPROPRIATE
WAY, THROUGH DIPLOMACY AND
DIALOGUE.
THAT'S W